[Music]
[Music]
whatup we're here hello surprise it's
the 3 p.m. Pacific time we're here play
in the division both not that great at
mathematics but we'll sure show you the
way in this cool third-person shooter
that we can play right now I'm gonna
switch it over cuz I don't know what I'm
saying any range for math Joe get ready
for it we're gonna run it in hello
everybody what's up hi so I'm gonna mess
up the volume a little you know people
see us here's hoping
yeah so we're literally like we just
started it up and we're gonna character
creation so you're gonna get the bullets
hekia time to continue yes so they
actually have options in the beta it was
just randomly generating okay so I kind
of take a peek at what we got there's a
lot going on in this character it Brian
says I'm about done with he's brining
FPS games done with any game that
requires running really don't have time
for it anymore it's understandable
hey man I'm kind of the same way I'm
always want to give every game a fair
shake yeah I I gotta say I enjoyed
playing the division not necessarily for
grinding but just to like play a thing
with pals I'm feeling head number 9 it's
a good head anyway moving on she's just
my skin tone here a little bit barely
does anything is this game only playable
in online mode I look at that eye color
they're like oh some of those very yeah
that's my like these are like my vampire
contacts Oh perfect
those are my vampire contacts actually
our PC hardware and settings we have a
sticky note for the suite we actually
remember it is that the sticky note that
looks like there's a lot more room there
that's awesome oh no I can't believe
this we had this perfectly crap what
does this one say hair options shotgun
shells are in the morgue don't remove oh
that's uh that's Knievel got some real
good holy crap easy reverse their
options are really good I like the
physics I appreciate their unkempt how
are we playing we're not not sure that
we got a access for coverage of the game
it's just available it's there for us do
they fix the health issue that they had
in the beta average Joe we'll find out
together as soon as we we get in what
you're seeing is us doing this as we go
I was a cool hat it had like anime
goggles oh there you go spice it up oh
heck yeah with the blue yeah feeling it
I guess a there's a really snappy menu
yeah they're loading it's just snappy I
really appreciate I do enjoy that
loading takes far too long also I got to
point out a weird thing that I've been
noticing in Ubisoft games lately is they
really into neck tattoos and I didn't
realize that that was as big a thing mud
mud neck tattoos I like that Scarlett
well they do like Nazis you're right Oh
Manny Rivera you're Manny Calavera
oh you're speaking of my heart my soul
right now it's exactly what I need is
that Zetas ma Jammu yeah here at the
full sleeve
now there they're definitely chug that's
all where to go what's up on the
shoulder oh that's really good I like
that a whole lot I'm gonna go with like
a sleeve yeah it seems like a good call
I agree gamers best I think the
customization might be actually pretty
good there's a lot more to it which I
appreciate
are you guys playing a press access
codes for for getting in and starting
our coverage working on views really
weird that's so dangerous looking like
Tatsu oh this is on the PC by the way if
any so this is all PC game players
singing all right I already love our
character this is perfect okay so it
wasn't an eye patch it was just
square square shades but you gotta go
with the Aviators oh yeah ooh tank top
she looks badass
dude I'm feeling it yeah yeah I say go
with it Oh shows off the more your
sleeve - I'm all about that these pants
are very I was gonna say they look kind
of like like like tarp tart material
with this one she's just going full
doesn't give a [ __ ]
some boobs take the boots patch and
that's all I got
oh and then do I want a hat you go old
mmm kind of like her hair messy oh
that's like a like a balaclava mask but
rolled up to the top of your head that's
a good call
bold to accept confirmed that character
lock it in
we're good to go oh yeah you've unlocked
everything you I just God
yikes first impression of the PC version
works really yeah I haven't touched any
graphic designers because it kind of
just went in which that's a no-no as the
new games you always let you mess with
the graphics settings before you start
the video game I'm not a fan of that but
it seems to have picked some decent
settings oh man it's a crab yeah now we
know it's it's for real or or we're in a
don't worry
it's a little a little loud that's good
jump over it okay good shots good shots
okay okay it's a tomb by the way it's
fine Monday yeah oh god I forgot it's
Monday I know we just started two two
streams in and it's not even Tuesday you
can't tell the PC version it might be a
stream compression thing but I'll tell
you right now what I'm seeing with my
eyes on the monitor yeah I mean that's
always the thing with like a live
streaming aspect especially a live
stream yeah good good looks very nice
Jonathan wants to know how are the
controls so far with the gamepad on the
PC feels fine
perfect I definitely prefer for me if
it's if it's third-person I've got to be
using a controller it just feels weird
otherwise how's the PvP we'll find out I
doubt my dude playing this with the
controller on PC yeah yes is that third
person shooter someone shut the
perimeter
the Aviators were a very good touch
awesome everyone here well they put the
camera on the end of the ladder here we
go again that can't be right
wait there's like a ship coming home
One Ring by land - oh there you go yeah
yeah oh we got shoutouts to the
abilities you can unlock that's a big
ship all the electronics shut off their
ships got an electromagnetic pulse
possible how is it possible
so my supposed to be the same character
that I was I'm a different character I
don't I don't know you're just a another
division agent in the world the world of
division the division extended universe
I mean really it's the Tom Clancy which
is really just the Ubisoft extended
universe yeah yeah here we go this is
that intro from the beta take a moment
yeah just kind of stop and reflect we
survived we survived without our coffee
and free Wi-Fi play the open beta I
really enjoyed it gotta have it now hey
it's on the way soon everyone will be
able to jump in in play for those who
can't open the game right now
I like cocoa puffs I think it's because
we have a code that is like early like
early early exit code that like weird
thing now where it's like okay the
game's an early access but we got a
press code which is like
like a few hours it was really like I
didn't know what to call this dream at
first I was like what is this is the
game out yet pre early access oh man
corn I say really stoked on this corn
that we were watching
they've made our world bleed it's like a
rave a laser beams and smoke wanted to
protect us and save what remains
beyond our shield I didn't actually
watch this all the way through during
the beta eventually I was just like I
need to get in start playing right save
us who watches the Watchmen oh well made
yeah it's been seven months since the
outbreak
oh seven seven months skip seven months
later I'm still wearing the same clothes
I wore that day yeah way they sing it's
seven months since the first game like
30 years after the first game or some
[ __ ] maybe I do I don't know man
I appreciate the colors that are being
shown here there's a lot of green I
really like the first divisions like
snow yeah I gotta say like this isn't
doing it for me quite the same way the
Division I won I do appreciate the color
stuff but yeah it's I miss because the
snow is such a different thing but see
how it holds up though six months after
the first game okay thank you
what we're seeing the soundtrack
Red Storm like every V Soph game like 20
Studios worked on this probably yeah
right yep yep there it is oh well they
just splash literally like six of them I
thought it was gonna be like a uh okay
like five do they have any we only had
five studios I mean like ten there's
like ten it's you know it's whatever
it's fine it's Congress a raid ah maybe
is that what is that what the rate is
you have to raid the government agent
take it down I'm gonna lie DC looks like
it's seen better days
yeah it looks rough
so you're just picking up in the mission
that you start off with in the beta
right away okay I think so I think we're
gonna head to the the White House we've
made it
load my pistol first rate is an airport
ooh
airport yeah I'd be down for it
so that's Garris right it might be my
money my voice is definitely Garris dear
pet pet the deer can you pet the dog
yeah it's very good what level are you
guys at
this is just the beginning of level one
I would assume I think this is the first
like real gameplay moment anyway it's
just the same thing as the beta my
recording stopped over there
Oh a second recording gone oh yeah
backups oh it is the same voice actor is
what Eric's saying in the chat yes
excellent we're gonna do some
calibrations okay I probably shouldn't
throw a grenade oh you got throw a
grenade that person's dead are they oh
they're definitely dead tossed a grenade
you're good wait okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah
nailed it did it
all right it's all this Christmas
decorations because the the virus
happened there in Christmas time yeah
it's sort of howling like fallout
everything's got Halloween decorations
because the bombs dropped on Halloween I
think I'd go and ruin Halloween like
that we're out in front trying to make
sure no one pops up from behind yes oh
that guy who didn't do his job
no used to busy yelling yeah I didn't
practice what he preached Andrew says
who's excited to ignore the release of
the division - hey there are lots of
other games out there you could play
right now that's fine as much as I
really want to try this I'll probably be
playing uh-huh yep yep there it is that
tech is still there I'll probably be
playing dumb let me cry tonight when
this game comes out maybe not unless I
find a way to get my hands on a copy
then that's my plan
I do appreciate that those exclamation
marks were there I don't think they were
there in the beta that man was on fire
does the division - come on the zombie
mode then be kind of cool like what if
halfway through the game it just turns
into like a zombie outbreak and no one
expected it
I know if I'd be excited or disappointed
yeah it's kind of a weird mix I'd be
like ah cool for keeping this thing
secret this whole time but also what if
it were something else I rather like Sam
Fisher show up or something oh yeah
that's what I want and then the game
just turns into Splinter Cell this is
actually just a stealth game that's what
we need like you do a mission with like
the rainbow team like that's what I want
oh fashion Aiden Pearson's iconic hat
shows up yep he's here to just hack
everything well there was a gun back
back behind yeah like there's a spot off
to the the far side bent like way back
in the night previous lon
that's don't got time for that yeah
because they give you like a free common
weapon and common equipment off to the
side I had to play a lot of this area
because the beta kept crashing when it
was the first access for it
I'd be down with Sam Fisher stepping up
and every random UV game to save the day
that's what I'm here for words
hello look at this monument ah this is
the White House
I discovered it I've learned I've
learned about it the game really wants
me to go check out my pre-order bonuses
yeah I was gonna say you've got a whole
bunch of clean oceans just put that on
all right I guess you can check it out
at some point but is there a lot of
customization this game character
creation seems to be a lot better there
we go
deliveries nope grants whoa hold please
oh you got new guns you got Secret
Service glasses you got oh my gosh oh
let's let's get it outside check out
some stuff then so I think you have to
equip the weapon you got there you go
ruthless cyber I think I think the other
stuff is all cosmetic yeah where do i go
to do cosmetics different menu
jeez their apparel there it is
here we go let's get it on the apparel
store log in change your pants dude
superior pants the the first searches
are superior you know you're already
there then all you got a pub your
t-shirt is this just a pumpkin thing
it's just a poke a t-shirt is this a pop
good thing uh cool a Stan agent agent
scarf got some scary masks down the line
but you got the fireman pants I like
take it off uh hey there you know your
knife gun oh I see you're previewing it
yeah I got I got it for my car once I
got emotes oh you got a rock papers you
can play rock paper scissors in this
video game we allowed to show pub cos
shirts hey you know things are getting
wild over here in the division - all
right let's do it
you can fully appreciate it though
because we were in the body armor that's
true now you can see my sick tattoos
though yes it's not as good
ah get that cutscene let's meet these
important characters this is you I'm the
Sharon see I've done it I'm Annie
I run comms I'm guessing the division
alert brought you here damn glad to see
you yeah all the way from like an island
screwed we are never since the JTF
imploded the city has become a
playground for murderers [ __ ] Oh
there are several main factions games we
could check in the sack
unfortunately we don't actually know
what set to villainy you can check
though yeah I've been able to provide
especially this is the division
fortunately our sticky note we're
thinking is it there that's crinkled up
one that's right the last did someone
actually do that she's operating at the
theater settlement on a priority mission
you should go check in with her if
anyone knows how to get these systems
back online
it's her nope that's that's a secret
message yourself the locals while you're
at you weren't meant to see it'll come
for them to know there's yeah what
happened to it some on the PC or
anything is it yeah it really wants me
no I - let's check the settings yeah
settings graphics ultra sense at all
trousseau it's set to ultra I think the
next stops is probably customs so that's
probably the highest it goes as far as
what ultra means shadowy hi hi whoa
reflection quality is on medium and
that's ultra weird there's a setting
about it I can't believe it I'm going to
not touch it for the sake of not
crashing her yeah I just want to keep
going okay so I think we're gonna go
talk to her
quartermaster she to learn how to use
some new abilities you know what when
you you might pick right off the bat
question because all the things are open
now it's like in the beta you only have
the drone seeker mine turret and the
turret pulse shield is really cool I
remember using that a lot in the first
one mmm come on chair hive what do you
think I I like the mine the mine was I
tried it in the beta for the first time
I really liked it doctor it's really
nice very cool you got three different
options - okay the coal is to find your
voice and let's pick a skill here oh you
also get the Kem launcher in the open
beta there you go so that was also there
I didn't get a chance to mess with that
though okay so it's making me unlock the
weapon slot yeah I think says it's kind
of the gimme for it too now you can
equip that sniper rifle mmm maps all
here go to the theater catch a movie
okay so it seems like it wants me to go
there do ya get the dark zones all
locked out
okay nice nice
all right I can't I kind of want to play
this because I'm just watching you go
through the the beta stuff and I'm like
man I actually really enjoyed playing
the beta we got a friend also wearing
their puppy outfit Flash Nemo dad I want
to see my tattoos keep those firemen
what specialization are you guys going
thinking survivalist but specialist is
also fun I haven't looked too much into
it yet so I don't know where I would end
up going but I switched to pistol again
I'll hold it down
I think nope that does not seem to work
huh double tap there it is actually it's
either holder double tap that's weird
I would have expected to behold okay
let's uh
I feel like this looks better than when
I also played it on a lunch PS Kover how
do you scope in click on the right stick
nope quick and lipstick scope plus up on
press up on the d-pad really weird right
bumper left bumper no those are still
your skills oh hello there hi nope that
was a really odd got y'all special
tactical vector alright we're going for
it when should we expect the review not
sure but like we all we all just started
off like pretty much right when we
started now so hopefully soonish I'm not
too familiar with DC ooh blue oh it's a
boot great to speed a speed a boot how
long will you guys be playing uh-oh
we've been going for about 20 minutes
now there's a deer in the street you
think maybe like another like like an
hour and a half kind of say normal deal
long enough to kind of just get in and
check stuff out this is great yeah this
writing is on point
nope you didn't get shot okay if we go
keep going down the street my favorite
thing there's some server stuff off to
the left a couple of signs where all
those people were gathered up together
everywhere the the have some things to
say and I'm sure they're on the left
side of the street they might be coming
up on
Pierre oh hello patrolling hello you
didn't tell her about it
what a punk
[Music]
just killed him I shooting him in the
knee where's the healbot didn't pick it
up we do have the seeker mine though
which is pretty cool spoke to me I feel
like there's more stuff here than there
was before I just didn't notice like the
green like stagnant water in the middle
of street I didn't notice a lot of this
overgrowth before either so feel like
there's there's difference bleh sure
there's there's more here let's try this
secret mine see I usually just drop it
at my feet that did its job heck yeah
it's your exotic for semi-auto it's a
semi-automatic sniper rifle I believe
yeah does at least two shots got weird
oh it's really weird that it has a scope
and you can't we can't find out how to
scope in I'm sure there's just like a
weird button combination we're out
thinking over something this is another
game where you can't go inside most
buildings yeah probably
oh hey kam incoming call from agent
who's calling me who are you
I was just sent to this theater yes this
is on PC we're running on ultra settings
the default ultra running around playing
on a controller because third-person
shooters how does it perform we only had
one weird hitch a little while ago that
might have been a server thing yeah
well that's been pretty smooth it seems
although like how the mind follows you
around that's really good I thought he's
trying to run away
[Music]
are you guys nothing else how you guys
have access to it we have special press
access codes they let us get in a little
bit earlier so we can start doing our
coverage girl review kind of geared up
oh yeah
so that's that's how we're playing right
now should be opening up across the
world as time goes on sure you guys have
seen the chart for it I don't know it's
probably up up on top maybe it's
probably not a way to get up there or is
there ah here we go
we found it what secrets do you have for
me blue box here we go
pop the runners is the downgrade like a
notch targets real I don't I don't think
so I haven't seen anything comparing it
to like if anything I think it looks
better than it did when I played the
beta I can say that how are we playing
this early am i able to buy and play now
we have a couple hours of earlier access
because we're playing a press copy so
that's how we're playing right now
hmm ha environmental storytelling that
person is having a bad day that means
this guy had a rough go at it it's not
exactly what he was hoping for you guys
played Metro or Far Cry new dawn oh not
all the way through it you play more
Metro I played I think it's a well-made
game I'm just sort of it's more farcry 4
farcry and I'm just really not yeah I do
want to go back and play more Metro yes
I really like Metro that but I was like
what if I play DMC 3 for the third time
are DMC 5 for the third time
oh yeah I want to keep playing Devil May
Cry literally before we came in here I
was playing mm I cry I'm thinking about
double May Cry now I can't stop devil
trigger is constantly playing in my mind
yeah do you think there will be a
blood-borne - why not sure hopefully I'd
be here for pardon minutes this time
shift has got me all sorts of messed up
the theater we found it I'm here for a
show uh-huh
roof this can top Devil May Cry 5 the
best game of 2019 a date I don't know if
it will top Devil May Cry 5 for me
personal yeah I was gonna say it does my
crap 5 spoke to me on many levels
yeah I just don't think this game can do
we got Secura coming up Sakura is gonna
be a kind of a close call for Resident
Evil 2 it's been a good year so I feel
like I put dumb a cry a little bit above
Resident Evil for me so far just because
resonable 2 was a game that i played a
while ago redone
in a really cool way sure it's all news
all new it's very apples and oranges for
sure oh yeah
but man resin able to is fantastic game
why aren't there any women I can spot
there are women I can spot yeah God sees
more women now definitely
I'm trying mean that in like a weird way
I just like you know more people more
diversity always good see DMC 5 vs.
Sakura which would you buy both yeah I'm
people
I would probably uh take away money from
whatever I'd use for buying food that we
can buy both of those games
personally I don't recommend it but ok
it's a thing that I have done before
what up dude how do I emote we're my emo
buttons at oh wait I think that was it
yeah there you go
shredder done he's got a cool shotgun it
looks like this guy but there's a selfie
pose it's this kind of its kind of
creepy like you just ran up to a dude
and like took a picture of him
Wow no one cares anymore in the
apocalypse there are no rules in here I
think of days gone rage - I'm excited
for rage - because it looks like big
open doom it'll be enough to hold me
over until doom happens because I'm very
excited for dooms did I mention doom I
think that's coming out this year I hope
so but DS gone oh I mean I'll play it
I'm not particularly like over the moon
excited about it snow doom but what are
your thoughts on anthem I spent 30 hours
playing I'm okay now
yeah I'm pretty whatever it's got some
things I like about it
I don't feel compelled to keep playing
any more right now until like they start
adding significant content so that game
yes even then it's more like I'll check
it out I'll be like right now though I
just I feel no desire like keep buying
my game yeah same
Caleb ass how's the vision - so far
let's let's get an update how you
feeling after shooting some dudes in the
street okay well right now we're just
doing sort of emissions access that were
in available in the beta yeah yeah she's
still kind of feeling about about the
same yeah why don't we let's kind of
keep going and see if we can get like
some new stuff right now
here we go the hard-hitting questions
from coverage
do you like ruffles what's your favorite
chip ruffles are just to remind you the
one the ones with ridges ruffles have
ridges ruffles have ridges very
important is the catchphrase that my
favorite type of chip is actually kettle
Oh kettle chips are very good kettle
chips are where it's at for me use a
kettle chip as a base you could build
off of that get some different like like
flavor profiles like a kettle chip brand
are you just do quell chip brand kill
chips there's a kettle brand just called
kettle this Sun this person's ready to
do what they gotta do Oh baked chips are
also good all right I like I respect him
as an alternative to like regular chips
because you don't have like the weird
oily feeling on your fingers I've
definitely can have thin plain-ass
potato like like regular particular ways
are so thinning greasy they don't feel
good on my hands I don't feel good in my
my tummy they just don't feel good at me
anymore I can't do that I can't I can't
mess with that yeah I feel the same I'm
beyond those unless they've got
different flavor dust on them I probably
wouldn't even look at him sure Dorito I
like to read oh it's some more corn it's
like a little bit it's a corn chip it's
it's a little bit thicker I feel like a
Doritos like you could sit down and have
like a meal with a Dorito like it's ah a
nice steak with some Dorito it's not
like a like a snack snack you know like
we're here you're like watching TV and
you're casually relaxing with like your
regular potato chips I feel like a
Dorito you've got to be sitting down at
a dinner table like you got to treat the
Dorito I get out the good silverware
today we're having some Cool Ranch
Oh Cool Ranch I haven't had that in many
moons desk from the rest of the bag just
pour it on that broccoli oh my favorite
perfect oh man trying to think of other
other type of chips uh so not really
chips but have you ever had like I think
they're called like Andy Capps fries
they're like really spicy like kind of
shoestring potato fry things very good
hello
quit that body hammer yeah there we go
I used to love those a lot they're very
spicy and very very delicious hot fries
but it know this was the vision - I'd
say it was Division one I feel like it's
kind of like a good iterative step yes
no there's no parkas there's no so the
signs melted that's how you know it's
sequel
see one of the spec to the PC drawn
ultra is this being demanding so we
don't have the sticky note with the
actual hardware anymore but it's it's a
I remember it being pretty good it's not
like top-of-the-line top-of-the-line but
it's maybe like a couple of steps under
like like a high high level PC and we
haven't had too many issues with it I
want to say it has a 1070 in it for a
GPU yeah I just don't remember I don't
remember either I feel bad saying one
thing or the other but I've got to go
off of is my memory drop my boy well
it's gonna take a couple seconds but I
dropped my boy Holly left division to
her Donkey Kong Donkey Kong all the time
my boy go that far I think so if you
sent him he's got to be able to go hop
the fence oh they all know wait if they
all get together what perfect
that was a dumb move oh the I like them
physics yeah those girls good MORTAL
KOMBAT 11 do a six that's another
situation where it's a bowl very
different
maybe moral combat because it probably
has more modes that can you can play yes
so there's there's a main path for the
story that takes like 45 minutes to
finish and then there's a whole bunch of
side stuff that takes maybe a little bit
longer so I'd say maybe like two and a
half hours put everything in the story
for DOA and it's not it's not great
story stuff look even as a person who
loves DOA it's not not too big not too
serious
but man I love fighting in DOA I mean
really that's kind of the but yeah I do
love definitely I just want to see more
John Cage I'm like surprisingly into the
more combat lore yeah right
October 31st speaking to both of our
souls and asking narrower Dante whoo we
were talking this morning about how we
really like Nero and five like that he's
I feel like like for I mean a narrow and
for but I just was kind of whatever
about him and I think I think just the
execution of what they were trying to do
with him didn't quite work out yeah they
didn't have enough time or something I
feel like five is like okay I get it I
get what you were trying to do with this
character and I really like him now so I
think uh because I said this last week
when we were doing another stream and I
don't remember what it was oh it was
probably Diablo or I thought I think I
like Nero more than Dante and that was
before I had actually got a chance to
play much of five if anything I think
five cemented the fact that I am really
in the Nero like I love Dante Dante's
great but I really like the way that
Nero plays I really like Nero's attitude
Dante is always just gonna be the cool
dude who's always there yeah for sure
certainly does not replace Tom as far as
playing them goes I'm talking more
attitude for sure first playing goes
better in Niro than I am at Dante Dante
is late almost too many options for me
at least right now I definitely I don't
I do like Dante a lot I really love the
cavalier like that's so much fun
all that crap that that weapon is like a
real nervous or something
wait you think yeah how it's listed in
my my list of yeah see yeah it's it's
list of a DLC snip that for like for
fitting a boss which is why I thought it
was weird that was in my DLC list that
can't that doesn't make any sense to me
at all let's see we're getting some
questions I think we're getting a couple
questions about the kid we're actually
playing so ask about the health system
if I find it changes the way I do and
gown it's it's a DLC it's an extra bonus
content that's not included in the game
no way no no no no that's the color
scheme for it oh that's the red color
scheme for it that would do it it's
gonna say no way they wouldn't make that
wet that'd be insane I feel like more
people would be like calling [ __ ] on
that that would explain it yeah shoot
the houses woman's in this game right
now if - at least so far I feel like I'm
being pretty bold you can get pretty
bold with stuff in this game it seems uh
when they start throwing stuff out like
when you get to the roof that's when it
gets kind of as fatty are we
Bob Jones Wilson oh are you doing the
review for the division - for GameSpot
I'm not he is not
I don't really review another question
pokemon sword or shield
I usually I'm always that person that'll
just counter pick what everyone else
picks that's kind of what I do to
support my friends yeah make sure that
we get all the Pokemon but I think
knee-jerk just like what I want I think
shield I like the idea of protecting
more than attacking no one of those
deals Division of Borderlands it's a
tough one - definitely got more into the
Borderlands in the division that could
have been like when I played it kind of
thing though yeah same for the
first-person nature of Borderlands yeah
let you kind of see your weapons that
you get to in there are a lot of yeah
like cool designs there and I feel like
there's more character in the characters
you choose oh for sure
yeah I think it's too soon to call how
we feel about the division in that I've
only been watching John Luke play it for
40 minutes I mean I guess if you were to
compare Division one to Borderlands I
definitely miss football
yeah
I just found an ammo stockpile I'm gonna
detonate it uh Nike wants to know do we
know one Call of Duty 2019 will be
revealed no we do not know either reveal
it 243 though there will be a Call of
Duty thing that happens at some point
though I feel that it's pretty regular
those rumors of the that pop to began
about my warfare to I be in for a master
for the campaign right give me my uh my
unpatched model 1887 again just the
campaign I don't kind of liked it and
multiplayer when they were broken I run
around around around Lebanon and I mean
I think the rumor is that it's only
gonna be oh that's what I've heard that
it's just the campaign interesting
prepare your shields real quick yeah
loves our picnic Battle Royale I miss
worms like worms
[Music]
via
what's going on Mario what do you got as
a question I'm sorry I missed it I see
that you were you were asking for
someone oh do we get loop from the
shield's right away uh I don't I don't
know I don't know I not familiar enough
to be able to answer it I guess
unfortunately do you think there will be
a Division three and where will it be
located I'm sure there'll be a Division
three division three Tokyo Drift there
we go just do a fast and furious kind of
go my pets
I get shotgun
yeah shotgun to be really cool
take this holster
worthy playing form to be in the game so
early were we're in San Francisco but
we're playing an early press copy which
is why we're we're in right now
so we gotta we got to get our reviewer
in and we'll start them playing so they
can get a review ready as soon as
possible so we've got a little bit
earlier access than than other people it
seems alright keep this training going
yeah keep mess them up these guys who
run down the hallways are my favorites
any loot I do appreciate that this game
does Telegraph like when someone drops
something very well yeah for sure I
don't feel like I ever miss picking up
anything
plenty of hostiles on the roof they tell
you say good things or you're only you
could be or you'd be blacklisted they
tell us that we don't do it I love it
we're just hanging out and playing the
game I don't know
I'm anything good or bad to say about it
right now to be honest yeah you're
you're just playing what was in the beta
right yeah so so far this is pretty
bog-standard shooting stuff I mean the
environments look nice but it's pretty
whatever at the moment for me honestly
like I don't think it's like I'm just
right now I'm pretty whatever about it
are you thinking about Devil May Cry
right now yes damn okay there it is
every day a good way to measure a game
for myself is am I thinking about
another game that I'd rather be playing
law and playing the one that I'm playing
you know if I'm playing the division and
I'm thinking about Devil May Cry am I
really enjoying the division that's
that's just me
no response oh dang you're in the no
respawn zone is there like a team
deathmatch so division has this really
cool kind of PvP thing we're like you go
into these designated areas or everyone
can shoot everyone and that's kind of
like the PvP deal right
we're special loot that drops there
you've got to extract it out everyone's
friends until someone sneezes on someone
and they all get angry it's very bad
very bad time yeah nice
whoa some fire happening
Oh apparently there's also a dedicated
PvP area or peepee urban area in this
game goal conflict how can you actually
just do PvP that's exciting I didn't
know about I feel about like I like PvP
in this game just like straight PvP yeah
I enjoyed the original division enough
to like step into the dark zone maybe
twice I did it for like a couple days as
my friends after B yeah they kept
playing for a while and I was like I'm
good
so I played the N for like a week yeah
not a fun time enough to kind of play
through it and enjoy it
yeah wait the story yeah I put in like
what 30 hours and I was like grind
system ow I mean I played the beta but
if you want to go back and see
everything I did in the beta the video
is still up I didn't see anything to do
with conflict at all in there
unless I I looked right at it and just
didn't pay attention to it
I was too busy running around being
stoked about stealing the Declaration of
Independence because I'm gonna be honest
more excited about heists than I am
about vvv that's just me
I'll see wasn't the base of operations
it was right in front of me I just
didn't even see it I got too distracted
by the fact that they had a barbecue set
up here we go did it go grab that loop
so many common items hekia how the music
in this game is good so DMC 5 but I mean
I don't know if you can really do this
thing it's no DMC [ __ ] I can't launch
something into the air and air convoy
music it's also not Devil Trigger is
there Devil Trigger the more I shoot
people the chorus doesn't kick in Oh
what if they did what they did that
that'd be really good if we ever were to
somehow get like a bullet storm hello
there this guy I feel like that'd be the
logical step for bullet storm have
interactive music man bolster really was
like the first-person shooter of Devil
May Cry games yeah I liked it a lot
probably more than I should have did I
at least have some barbecue nah they
wouldn't offer any to me I walked over
there and they just didn't want to do
anything with it
rage too is kind of basically bullet
storm but there's something about bullet
storms like actually scoring everything
and it like specifically encouraged you
like it have the DMC thing where it's
like hey if you do different things you
the score goes up like D straight up
just were like what if it's da devil may
cry but with like a shotgun that has
four barrels on it exactly or a revolver
that also shoots fireworks out no also
the sniper rifle was really fun she just
gets a bend the bullets
check some his loot I got David asks do
you think Rage 2 is better than Anthem
I haven't played rage 2 but I feel like
it might be better than anthem for me it
just speaks to my particular style of
game playing oh yeah there we go
can I shut Deconstructor Markus junk
which one is more useful in this game I
don't remember oh shoot you got a cool
mask used on survival I haven't heard
anything about survival I also haven't
been paid too much attention to what's
going on unfortunately but survival was
really cool I heard a lot of people
really enjoyed it uh what does GameSpot
mean is it GameSpot or GameSpot it's
named spot GameSpot is a do you look
forward to our future sister side game
you keep GameSpot GameSpot were we very
excited about that you're really excited
about potting plants all your plant
plant pot income rotting plants in one
spot you know keep it locked if you're
gonna grow plants inside your garage you
really want to use this type of fan yeah
it's a real important thing keep in mind
does everyone in California try to be an
actor only the people in Los Angeles as
a person from the Midwest that's my
impression yeah that's like I'm from
Vermont oh yeah that's right we're both
like not from here at all so I only
really run into like the the wannabe
movie types when we go to LA for yeah
here it's all tech pros yeah oh so many
technical oh yeah
apex legends are fortnight apex apex
without a second guess 100% I can't
handle building in fortnight no I can't
either
so I'm immediately I also don't like the
way the guns feel
learn more about plans I'm curious too
that door down okay good huh
hi I'm also a person who's like if there
are people who enjoy playing fortnight
and it makes them happy like I don't
play play whatever makes you happy
it's not for me I'm gonna stick to Apex
for now and hopefully we'll get that uh
that pass soon we'll have more
objectives to do in that game rather
than just run around and win like we do
every day throwing it down dude yeah
there's a lot of menu pop oh and do
pop-ups all happening at once who you
lookin like a like Oh a Raiders UI from
Burning Crusade World of Warcraft's
pinna play Burning Crusade and raid this
is really bad this is a I realized that
I should probably not nighttime do that
kind of thing we got a good cycle yeah
yeah I'd be really excited to see if
apex adds a single duo and then like a
four-person squad four-person squad
might be kind of weird but yeah stop the
and start another one sounds like a plan
well I was probably not the game those
probably the computer trying to like the
recording yeah
colonial wants to know if your parents
named you after jean-luc Picard because
it's that's the question actually yes
there you go they did confirmed
[Music]
there they really like Star Trek so when
they were coming up with names they're
like oh you're like the name gentleman
that's going in the captain but it
wasn't like we want to pick a name
we love Star Trek so therefore he will
be named Jon Lieber card it was more
that they liked Star Trek they thought
they were watching Star Trek well my mom
was pregnant with me and they really
liked the name John oh not necessarily
like I loved this so therefore my child
will be named that like ah I'm gonna
name my kid Bowser because these are my
main in Smash Brothers you just happen
to really like the name Bowser quite a
name my kid Solid Snake because I love
Metal Gear how do you guys have the game
we have a special press access that
gives us a way in a couple hours
beforehand just so we can start up on
our review and coverage but the game
should be rolling out here soon for a
lot of people I don't exactly know the
time and time zone for stuff but it's
it's tonight it's not too far off I
don't know if giving us access to a game
so we can do our work on it is
necessarily a bribe no oh I don't know
if that's how it works no I mean it's
the way it it's it's kind of meant to be
is like a mutually beneficial thing
where the ideas they give you the game
early so that you can cover it and talk
about it
and the they're hoping that you'll enjoy
it and that you'll talk positively about
it so that you know then you're giving
word-of-mouth yet obviously we aren't
beholdin to say anything
oh it's joke sorry the text doesn't
convey stuff well enough I'm just kind
of like oh here we go sorry man so good
yeah it's just the thing is is a lot of
people a lot of people do that aren't
joking when they say that to us
and so when you see that in text we just
assume
you're not joking because a lot of we
see a lot of people who don't joke but
we appreciate about it you are you are
joking but if you are joking that's yeah
we appreciate that yeah thank you I'm
not these projects yeah let's find a
thing to expand upon you need a hundred
steals so oh I need to give them stuff
yeah I think that's to help build out
the camp oh I can like donate items and
that equates out to steel pieces you
okay that's kind of okay you know what
kinda like that yeah that's nice sure I
play the first division is this better I
haven't played a lot of it division so
long so as far as like that my new
details I can't really say oh we can say
if I'm not the best person that one
thing objectively I think there's more
customization for your character in this
game more customization I mean it still
feels good but it just feel very similar
yeah for sure the UI doesn't really
bother me this one the way it did and
the other one but I also know they
improved it a lot like since then and
again that sort of a like just like I
wasn't I didn't stick with the game so I
couldn't speak to like oh like you know
what that game ended up being versus how
this one is yeah oh you're getting
shotgun got it hey Daniel asks a pretty
good question who's your favorite apex
Legends character oh I like Bangalore
I think Bangalore is pretty cool I'm a
pathfinder guy through and through if
you want to hear me talk about how much
I love that sweet sweet robot boy we've
got some some guy Sonic's I guess that
we know but I got to help with the the
Pathfinder one so give us some cool tips
on how to zip line better can I am I'm
not skilled here or no do I have to go
back to my base to do that
got barbecue yes that's the barbecue I
was talking about barbecue that guy is
in a really weird place he's just like
next to the the barbecue buying that
person sweeping reef seems pretty cool
too yeah
great that's cool I find lifelines very
valuable I'm scared I dislike at least
on a fight so far the only one I I'm not
really feeling is the gas man hostak
yeah he's uh he's real gross all the
side quests man let's do it is the
sponge stuff still a thing in this one
it seems like it's less bad at least
just from watching you kill Fisher yeah
it doesn't seem as bad from what I
remember but I'm wondering how long that
holds out like is it just gonna be you
later on you're gonna run into dudes
with a lot armor yeah you know hard to
say
blueberry we're playing on the PC right
now with an Xbox controller
I'm a nya I'm gonna be helping out at
the base of operations with equipment
fabrication it's a pleasure to meet you
I mean you're gonna 3d print me a gun
here's hoping crafting
okay Nike wants to know what her
favorite racing game is paradise
burnout paradise is a good choice for
the horizon it's another one that I'm
really into fire where prevails over a I
agree same big same I am helping just
not that camera work we shake it's uh it
makes it real like you're actually there
we fail alright alright I gotta say her
character models yeah
October asks why are we playing with a
controller not keyboard and mouse I know
that I'd I wouldn't do it because I like
third-person shooters with controllers
over keyboard and mouse pretty actually
that's that's my reason I feel the same
way yeah and if you really want to see
the try keyboard and mouse just see how
it feels but you did your part I won't
forget
to do
see you later goodbye you could have
said anything okay get the flare gun got
some missions to get let's say let's do
this man let's do some stuff
we should head back to the white house
to get a new tech right yeah yeah
also someone here offers a mission on
this roof to steal the Declaration of
Independence whoa how do I do that you
have to talk to them and get it from
them I don't remember who it is but it
was in the beta and it was the best part
after one lock that put that in the beta
like do you play rainbow 6 with the
mouse yes because it's a first-person
shooter
oh yeah yeah of course that is a like
you know heavy tactical multiplayer
first-person shooter yeah I'm gonna play
it on PC I'm gonna play it on a
controller alright I'm sorry mouse
keyboard not control um let's go back to
the base and get me a skill let's do
some stuff I don't even know you could
quick travel I actually just ran back
through the streets and did side
missions on my way to travel the first
game right
am I crazy am I I don't remember maybe I
just walked it out I was I was a mess
David also asked what games we're
looking forward to this year doom yeah
absolutely
suck your oh yeah drown whatever they
have unannounced so the drone you can
use to actually heal yourself with like
that oh I think Syria I think the fixer
is the one cuz yeah it repairs your
armor I kinda like that
get more of a support role it's pretty
good that's nice okay Oh always
inventory space Mortal Kombat very
excited for Mortal Kombat always get me
more inventory that's just a no-brainer
there yeah okay
it's good everyone how's it going double
TJ how are you on this
oh god it's Monday I forgot again safe
house how are you doing on this this
Monday we'll go to that safe house
I hope so I'm very excited for more
Wolfenstein that give me co-op or
something right I think so that's kind
of cool shotgun ha no Evie says that
there they're probably gonna end up
dying tonight because they're gonna pick
up division to their local retailer head
back in play and sleep for only two
hours of going to work tomorrow Bank is
commitment heck yeah she all stock up on
some snacks and some drinks stay
hydrated drink a lot of water you'll
thank yourself in the end
very important
so the the best job ever it's it's
definitely a like a silly dream job and
I love it every day that I'm here and to
be honest doing these live streams just
kind of like my favorite parts of it cuz
I could just hang out with like John
Luke you play games but also hang out
with you guys it's definitely one of the
better perks I got paid to play
blood-borne this morning so I really
can't complain yeah that's a pretty good
deal don't go to work until 10:00 a.m.
tomorrow
let's check otherwise some some not good
things happened I'm came out left my
refrigerator running I had to go catch
it did you want a second Dreamcast heck
yeah
not a friend though Adam seemed I got a
chance to play some yeah I want Power
Stone back I still think Sonic Adventure
2 is a really good game I like my
Dreamcast play more uh was a dynamite
cop one of those one of those games I
have early exes and I can't download the
city you should be able to preload I
think
or play it you haven't pre-loaded okay
okay so you're you probably just waiting
for the the release window to happen for
you tomorrow I think early access starts
tonight like midnight for like these
coasts and maybe 9:00 for us possibly
I'm not sure there's a whole chart that
we soft put up that tells you when it is
supposed to happen wherever you are they
did the famous Ubisoft charts yes the
the map with the times for launch we're
only playing right now because we have
an early access press code so we're just
getting our coverage ready for you guys
so we can get our review done exactly
some cool cool features that kind of
thing play Sega Genesis heck yeah all
right there we go I didn't ever own a
Sega Genesis by a friend of play this I
played a lot over there what are our
thoughts on the PS 5 having backwards
compatibility you think they'll have it
or not I don't know if they will they
won't but I hope they do because I
really like the backwards compatibility
functionality on my xbox one and I'd
like to see it in more places the
Intellivision was actually one of the
first systems I ever played old old
sea-dog
my dad had in television with every game
available on it my mom had an Atari 2600
with every game available on it and that
was my first like whoa video games what
is this
so I played a lot of Night Stalker it
was my favorite one on the Intellivision
I like that a lot I'll play a lot of
pac-man on the Atari I didn't know that
it was the worst version of the game
didn't matter cuz I thought it was
really cool yeah when you don't know you
don't know exactly rag oh shoot I got
this really cool joystick with one
button yeah they got me real early so
that was really fun
so I did that and I did like PC stuff
until I got my own Super Nintendo later
on I don't know what you're supposed to
do when someone's calling for that do it
it's really weird you have to hit this
button and then you have to scroll over
oh and then you go to answer the call
that seems very out of the way
ghostbusters 2017 answer for callers
it's wow that's a really an elegant way
to do that cuz it's like oh you hit the
button and then it's like it doesn't
tell you have to then go to that menu
and then hit the button yeah I was not
the best system I would make that like a
singular button press somewhere oh shoot
the lock yeah you should the lock is
like a bike lock yeah heck yeah cool ooh
there we go no players in fear no more
do you have to manually join Iran I
think you will see more people it's just
that there aren't many people playing
wandering around hoping the audio bug is
fixed yeah literal hyenas alright now
it's a dog oh jeez I was like what how
did this guy met him
oh he's gonna run away I'm not gonna
attack you though I spent half of the
love you my time running around in the
streets during the data stream just
trying to track a dog
oh really so they don't even people let
me show up and figure out unless you
invite them probably oh that's how the
first game work didn't it it is right I
forgot it's a good shout brownie I even
realize whoa hello hello there just hit
you and ran away also hold on I have a
shotgun oh heck yeah
now you're in business help with
anything I can I appreciate it because
it would be honest while I love doing
these streams and like hanging out with
everyone I'm definitely not entirely up
to date on everything that's going on
with a division or not so it's really
nice when we have people who were able
to help us out
see you're doing a service
Oh what about true crime I missed your
crime and if you liked your crime you
didn't play Sleeping Dogs you should
play Sleeping Dogs
because leaving dogs is the spiritual
successor of crime so good it's very
good I love that game yeah same sleepy
puppies
okay huh I look at all these these boxes
in here no on the flute well put that
you warmer Oh see so I want quick why
did that right nope I did not do that
yes this is on PC we're playing with an
Xbox controller having a good time
personal computer status okay there dude
it's it's four o'clock how are we alive
what how we how are we how are we still
here alright man let's do it
kick that door down I do you have the
side missions in Division one always
being like pretty involved yeah I was
pretty impressed with that like they
weren't ended up going inside of places
at like pretty like unique places I
didn't feel very cookie cutter stop
games do I remember thinking that was
cool oh my god finally oh jeez person
yeah like he's got a gun yikes
the graphics settings are set to ultra
the default right now yep default ultra
with us most things on high a couple
things looks like this may be a setting
above high whatever the default entry is
this
at that computer heck yeah the person
said to I with like seven eyes
who
so I'm bored I'm just real tired Dustin
I maybe stayed up too late last night
playing DMC fair like as soon as as soon
as we all decided to get off of apex at
like 12 and I really thought we were
playing it for I was like I really want
to play some DMC before I go to sleep
and then I accidentally stayed up and
played a bunch of DMC it's gonna find a
path he's gonna do it what a good boy
robot I kinda liked that he tried to run
away oh hello what shotgun it's just
like a common regular shotgun there's
some weird hold on a second
it was rely on uh like a good a que that
it's a good good place to be faithful
oh shoot you unlocked your healing drum
but you never said it
oh shoot ah that's a good call actually
I did the same thing during the beta I
don't think about I have to go back to
the store no you just do it in the menu
okay yeah there you go
whoops who was a close one
I was about to be like yes probably use
that huh then I totally forgot about
that whoa look at these heels heck yeah
call it a lifeline package there it is
dropping a health drone job whoo I just
polished my grapple I just supposed my
grapple is a big a big mood feeling that
I think it that line is definitely
enhanced by the fact that he says it as
he's like swinging in yeah you like taps
his chest he's like I just polished my
grub he's very excited about he wants to
let you know ya love pathfinder he's
such a killer
the Hey look here I am drone ah my
favorites again just it just gotta give
away my position it's like I wonder if
the person stealing
looks like they are
oh my drum and when it made it over
there can we play right now I think it's
still unlocking in other areas we have
early access because it's a press code
these guys a little bit bullet spongy
not to those drone sticks around for a
really long time Yeah right maybe they
have to take it out I just he's still
there are you finally finally
disappeared
how's the business thing as the first
camera better I enjoyed playing the beta
but I also kind of enjoyed the first
game it feels like you're playing the
division so I guess if you enjoyed it
I definitely not yeah okay I feel done
but I'm from Michigan so when can i play
well being a person who is also from
Michigan you're in the eastern time zone
I believe unless you like down down on
the southern part of Michigan where the
time zone likes to change and be
different from the rest of this house on
me that was duh so probably Rizvan
should be a moan I got I got too cocky
there Oh God and then our change happens
so yeah it's probably 11 what is
happening oh wait no it didn't even oh
it didn't even like checkpoint me it's
after I killed them then the guys
disappeared that's me so like you see
the loot still here oh that's weird like
the loot still here but now I do have to
reopen that's weird can you farm people
like Johnny with us like you just kill a
bunch of high-level dudes die and then
reset it I'm kind of curious him you
could do that sure we got farming strats
already alright these are the pro strats
well so it's not so much as a not
knowing time zones it's that
specifically in Michigan it's mostly the
eastern time zone but if you're far
enough south you're actually falling to
the central time zone because for some
reason like a couple of the the counties
down there want to be special and unique
yeah and then there's also daylight
savings and then there's daylight
savings that just happened to change
everything by an hour on top of it so
it's a real weird like 3 2 hour shifts
like it's dumb we should get rid of
daylight savings it's stupid I'm tired
of it definitely that
also Michigan what the heck man get your
time zones together I love you we've got
dangerous weather please figure out your
time zone problem thanks for being kind
with your like hey no problem I I
understand I I remember being in the
same place where you're just like man I
just want to know what my date comes out
when can i play when can i play my video
game so no worries and i hope you enjoy
playing your video game when it does
come out what's the red light on the
backpack I think that's telling him that
his mine is ready to go oh I think
that's my baby that your your drone it's
I think it's my mind yeah
dad
yikes oh we're playing on PC but we're
playing with an Xbox controller
are there any stealth mechanics
definitely my mind not that we've seen
you can like set up your your ambush
form you start fighting people but I
think you just fight on this death
stairway a plus you could probably call
it your drone maybe I already did
oh nevermind oh hello there I'd hit that
that thing is rebuild your shields there
you go we're just trying to play
Division two on hard mode where we don't
repair our arm yeah that's where we are
I'm personal challenge we're inspired by
playing blood-borne earlier it's going
going through the hearts difficulty we
can also cuz I haven't done it all over
in the last maybe ten minutes of the
stream Oh a blue uh I'm going to say hey
if you're enjoying what you see you
should definitely subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss a single show
that we do we usually stream every day
at 11 a.m. Pacific every weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific I mean not during the
weekends I'm sleeping during the
weekends yeah we do all sorts of early
game play like this sometimes we'll do
impromptu streams like this but we'll
always play cool things and always have
a good time and I look forward to hang
out with you guys
John Luke and I actually do a show every
Friday where we play video games with
you guys this week
maybe I think I think the Mortal Kombat
beta is they told me that it's supposed
to be happening on Friday okay that
would make for a good press so I think
we'll play mobile combat on Friday heck
yeah and I hope that they let us set up
rooms so we don't actually get I doubt
it usually bands don't let you do that
for free games but that doesn't matter
we're gonna make it happen anyway we'll
try to queue up at the same time yeah
we'll make it happen we'll do it kick it
old school so if you want to hang out
with John Luke and I while we play the
new Mortal Kombat and DEF
kind of flailing around a bit while we
try to learn it it'll be a good time one
more mission yeah whatever you're
feeling I'm down up do you man and how
are you feeling I'm it's 4:30 but I'm
having an all right so I'm hanging the
guy think you got to take care of her
work oh nothing like I did I could just
keep going because I really don't have
much else going on today yeah there
wasn't there wasn't anything lined up
before I came in here I guess let's get
that cash
there you go swish - son son of Sparta
mode yeah that's what we need to do
mm-hmm I'm really excited to play heaven
in hell there you go
Dante must die just keep keeping I
really do I don't know if I'll play it I
would play it but I really do hope they
add a um must aisle mode and yeah I
think that was a cool thing that the
reboot had especially now in this game
because the music it's good when you get
to that level so before she to get to
the part where the music's really good
but I don't know that was a mode and
double my craft DMC Devil May Cry where
you could only do damage to enemies if
you had an S I'm going yeah is that on
PC with an Xbox controller you bet it is
that it is people sure love asking about
that a house the enemy III seems like
they're making it too easy to kill them
it's it's pretty basic for sure yeah
they run away from grenades they run
away from getting shot they'll try to
take cover but I haven't seen anything
like spectacular yeah then you can
murder them I'm into it all that nip
commander this is the math expansion
this is the addition to the division
it's got that question mark how long
have you been playing for about an hour
and a half huh how are we playing this
it's not unlocked yet we have special
access because it's press a press code
or for making sure we can start on our
review and coverage so we get a little
bit of a head head start early access
Neil as the character create our
customization good it seems like it's a
bit expanded from the first game we
actually made this character at the very
beginning of the stream if you want to
check it out it can roll it back it's
got their creation in there but it seems
like it's a bit better this time around
oh Jesus whoa
hey that was ah boo
dang it had to happen eventually and
that was rough yeah gank when is the
review as soon as we can possibly get it
done sure thanks Oh all right after we
talk about the the I being pad we get
beat down it's how it goes they heard
yeah yeah they were like we'll show you
bad get us locked in the corner I works
okay I'm I guess I can go out back
that's what I was a control point oh
thanks oh yeah the flag yeah
are those control planes how's our new I
don't remember those being the original
yes so you you go and you take them and
then you get like supplies and do they
eventually read get taken back like
infinitely replayable infinite dragons
who loves thank you I feel like that the
like damage that enemies can take and
maybe the I'll probably ramp up as you
go
ad make sense actually choose you guys
Rock we try as best we can I'm glad that
sure you're enjoying yourself and we're
able to help you out I'll call your
nearby allies hey what's up guys what's
up oh yeah they took the drugs that's
why they're like oh that's why they
charge we've got like a like a Mad Max
kind of thing going on hello there
definitely prepare that envelope quick
can you pick up cans of beans and throw
them
I hope so men do
so kind of shocked that in the division
none of these cars on the street work
right
I feel like [ __ ] that be the next
logical step like hate maybe expand out
the area and let you drive when she
drive like cars kind like a an urban
setting for Ghost Recon wildlands kind
of thing but the division public in
uniform animes
like ei always uses frostbite so I can
say that Ubisoft teams all have like a
very similar look to us because they all
use the same kind of engine oh it's not
the same agent we're getting in okay
what's with the brightness yeah it seems
kinda great yeah it's just kind of the
the tone this games going for midday
there we go
you could call for backup hit that
button shiny though yeah
let's got this one actually nope never
mind
there you go this is just like AI yeah
I'm pretty sure Tainui comes up this is
the same one that I did during the beta
the enemy leaders here
Oh bill isn't wasn't great are you in
the dark zone now this is just the
regular zone she's that man spreading
through the middle of the street not
even caring but from are we playing on
this is on the PC with an Xbox
controller BAM
oh that was the leader did you like
shoot grenades on his belt or something
I don't know man
alright guys thanks for showing up it's
also you have like nothing yeah then I
feel bad
there's people with with guns do you
know how how big the game was when it's
all that with how how much it had to
install oh hi in check shoot I saw a
thing over the weekend where they were
saying I'd be like a 8090 gig download
oh wow that's that's gonna be a thing I
don't know which system that was for
them
they're kind of like the gun son of the
game yeah the guns sound pretty good
well market gun get up on that that
turret
oh nevermind they've got it I guess Hey
okay goodnight do you mind you're kind
of hogging mom said it's my turn please
my turn all the acts by the gun
I'd really like missing game you're not
even using it right
well it's you're even hitting up like
I'll do it hey I'm gonna hit them oh now
he's now they go off we're all dead
actually no they're not oh then yeah
give me my turn
if you want to do so bad please go
that's like it
and then you over to you what's that ham
is that it we did it
there you go you captured the fallen
cranes we did it
heck yeah yeah people were saying 92
gigabytes on the ps4 I think that's just
for the update oh look at this
oh yeah that's like like an old old
timey gun you got like a world war ii
thing going on where's my ping I think
yeah when I shoot all the shots out of
it
nope nothing I can't believe this can
you pet dogs though I don't think so we
a dog ran away when we try to pet them
so I'm gonna say now well yeah yeah go
back to the supply room and get the
weapon from him there
it's like you you unlock a bunch of
stuff by actually doing these oh oh so I
should go in here and get the thing yeah
like in the in the building
oh good to know not because I walked
away from it without realizing that I
was supposed to grab a thing so I think
so oh yeah there you go
an mp5 I'm going to and yeah then I
think I can split swap it and it will
swap the shotgun I think that'll work
sounds good I'll describe that that
systems little cumbersome a military MK
17 some steel electronics
that seems better a modular holster yes
I got just saying and then I got heck
yeah this thing alright let's try it out
look cool thank you go to my sick loot
yeah yeah yeah you should be able to pre
download it on every platform right now
so if you've picked it up should be all
the preload have it right there for you
ready for the unlock dog can I pet you
know run away
oh now joke over there you're gonna get
shot Oh save that dog that's a good gun
just level up grass
yeah the the 2-shot rifle is a very good
call keep that around since no one else
dares to ask I will is it better than
toads treasure tracker for the switch
tough call it's pretty good I do like my
system some caps man Admiral burger
yikes go on inside see what they got in
there the barbecue bacon and beef I
would actually I do that a fleam case
now only six dollars dang
yeah that looks pretty alright the
Admiral classic that's a thick patch you
start with the base that's a thick patty
that's a very thick pad it is yeah
whoa boy we aren't messing around over
here two Admirals there's an expresso
machine at the Admirals
yikes damn the condiment table is pretty
untouched we can't take that so that's
one of it you could do like a order
machine yeah you're just a pickled
peppers and apples that's a dangerous
thing there's some like potatoes in
there to really kind of random to be
honest with the Admirals about two
things burgers and bell peppers yeah
more expresso expresso that's a WOD
thing to have at a burger joint don't do
it that there was I saw what you're
right lined up for taking it with me
what about upstairs
yeah real chicken start with the
businesses you can't say start with the
basics again no yeah come on who did all
the marketing for this that works
ooh that's like a spicy chicken yeah I
like that give me one of those the
classic bacon of a classic chicken the
other chicken why would you put your
marketing behind your seats that's
covering it man I want to know I want to
know the menu so you've got the PC
version you just go into the image files
and pull out yeah that thing so you can
you can find it out there is the
backpack at the door thank you
it had work boots no one works harder
than the Admiral he's a real go-getter
okay they're making me hungry I'm making
myself hungry yeah I'm kind of feeling
it I had had a chicken wrap for lunch I
don't know if it was enough now I'm
thinking about the Admiral throw some
bad guys over there oh hello Oh
oho you were not wrong yeah guys like
busy crack in my neck
expresso in my fast-food restaurant it's
more likely than you might think
already mo thank you see that was those
nicely got a little drone hanging out
now good time question mark what could
it be
let's find out whoa
hey there expositions propaganda
broadcast oh that's what it is eight
meters away
oh is this better than an anthem
I feel like even without playing the
full game to me I think this game would
is probably better than anthem I'll say
it's more polished than anthem yes
you haven't crashed once the missions
haven't broken their scripts yet yep
there you go I feel I feel bad I feel
like there's there's promise and anthem
there is anthems definitely a game that
I feel like has a lot of promise isn't
there yeah for me I think I feel like a
fully realized anthem I would like
better than a fully realized division
yeah you know what I mean yeah I know
that's kinda where I feel I just I mean
I don't think it is fully realized I
think this is more fully realized than
even an anthem so off speaker controls
okay won't shoot shoot him blow him up
there you go restore the broadcast could
really do with a long sleep I feel the
same way subtitle okay I got a there's
gonna be some waves get your birthday
well happy birthday Andy I hope you have
a good day
get them
second Feliway here you're like to to
roller mind kills away from giving it a
name
ooh well should we name it Randy the
roller mine get Randy get him Randy sick
of boy sick him boy uh difficulty I
think we're just playing on normal
yeah prompted for a difficulty and it
actually didn't promise yeah this is
live in the u.s. already not live in the
US yet but we have access of your a
press code that we were given to start
on our coverage of it get our viewer in
the game start them playing so they can
start getting them all that together yes
that's how we're playing ooh I have a
yellow yellow yellow go grab that thing
that means it's got a perk on it right
maybe I'm just channeling apex I don't
know man solute system work in this game
oh it's he that's that one second might
be like a story now I've come across
these uh the Box socks yeah a little
less exciting the hyena boxes I was like
oh man legendary gear already Katherine
came out and laid it on you before you
got a [ __ ] this icky Katherine uh if I
were to review it now I don't think you
they're also played enough to review it
oh definitely not
and Jojo luke and I are our people the
the do reviews we don't do more more
video but I'll say so far I'm feeling
pretty whatever about it it's it's well
made
and I'm sure our shooting people this
gun it's not doing this the business
though solid but unsurprising yeah
that's a good way to put it so far I'm
like yep this is kind of what I expected
he's definitely I think about it has
really blown me away or anything this is
the division throw your damn hands up
seems well-made though we did it
heck yeah you got a medium breather for
it - oh I love medium I love getting a
good medium breather sure see that's
that's the thing
we aren't anywhere near the endgame we
aren't anywhere near playing for we have
played for two hours yet exactly we
played for like two hours it's it's not
it's not it's not really a game I can
review - zippy what if you get like an
admiral employee
I'd be very into that does that gun
Draganov SVD or a DMR type I think it's
more of a DMR yeah there's there's not
so much it's it's kind of like a like an
old like World War 2 na na there you go
I miss playing Halo uh but are you
having fun I'm having fun just because I
get to hang out on a livestream with
with John Luke and all you they should
be more goofy like I should go to like a
like a Revolutionary War Museum and grab
like a musket oh hell yeah
followed somebody six did then what and
uh that game ain't good but that was
pretty fun we've got a cool division
we're just like put through the filter
of like the saint row development
process okay like what what about that
so wants me to secure the perimeter
there's a lot of text popping up that
doesn't have a lot of words being saying
yeah
the game really wants me to hear this
stuff okay I'm just gonna keep going to
that mission is read dead whenever [ __ ]
in that game that you just run errands
on a horse that's pretty much what the
online boils down to now hundred that
game single-player and I really hope
they do some stuff for the multiplayer
cuz where it's at right now isn't isn't
my particular favorite she's got some
dirty genes from dirty vintage jeans
rocking them there wasn't rain in the
beta this is new content shut that man
again there you go
oh we got mannequin physics was our
person behind you who swore I saw
someone's like head pop up in the bottom
right it was really weird it was I guess
so tom tom clancy's the ghosts tom
clancy's fear man
do you find the font in the bottom
left-hand corner too small it's kind of
small
yes but I don't think it's too small I
can still make it out read it
oh there apparently was rain in the beta
this is not new content oh we're going
on an emotional ride right now
oh shoot we got some some heads up if
you wanna see real cool rain if we go to
the easy and wait until the the night
when it happens it's not the best bloom
that Barney makes thinks they've seen oh
I'm down for suggestions for a seat cool
things video games that's a good show
brownie make some curious is your last
name brown I had a friend in high school
whose last name was brown and they would
go by the name brownie mix Oh what if we
find out this is this is the person you
knew Oh that'd be crazy
have you really fun oh they said yes
that is the case that their last name is
brown may end up going out some person I
know but yeah so that's I called it
that's exciting though Colorado is a
pretty cool place though yeah if you're
the person I know if you you would know
me you would know me you like ah they
probably would have came in and said
odds John Luke exactly from school I
remember you okay so I'm secure the
crabs waiting for dudes to show up
father rains made it again it is really
weird wouldn't you like you're doing a
stream or something and then people you
know find you hmm like people who you
haven't talked to in a long time like I
was ahead cuz I played a lot of World of
Warcraft
I had the main thing my reading guild
actually find me while I was doing a
livestream once Oh weird hey man you
haven't popped in the raid in a while
I'm like I haven't talked to you in a
long time but it's really cool to see uh
oh my god what is happening but yeah
it's telling about how you've let the
clan down the regroup I've got I've got
a bad history of just people
I think they're up there telling me to
secure the courtyard but then there's a
person who's up in the other radar
saying there's there's someone over that
way I can can you shoot lights in this
game I don't think so
you can in they just spawn unless it's
like the glass under yeah the light
doesn't break put the glass breaks oh no
one bro there you go okay this one
anyway
this guy isn't really seem to be
spawning in or something maybe this is
like the anthem
oh no throw your damn hands up oh I
swear they're just like up there but I
can't really seem to interact there must
be like a finger here hold on can you
pull out your your roller mine and then
see if you can like target up up there
like it throw it okay so it can see that
there's a person there
yeah it knows there's a person there or
something the question is so if you can
like go back enough to like aim at that
thing above their head hell yeah
did it hell yeah from downtown
nailed it okay now I can go in that
elevator
perfect all right you know what if there
is if there's some weird stuff going on
I'm happy that you can at least sort of
fix it you're so able to get out we were
able to move past it at least that's
good
get my rollin boy Sikkim Randy get him
Randy show him what you got oh they
could Randy stuck in the elevator they
don't know to climb ropes oh no Randy
I feel bad you've abandoned them my boy
my son I'll come back for you
we're playing on the PC with an Xbox
controller because everyone knows it's
better to play third-person shooters
with a controller I'm gonna say that I'm
gonna that's my hello I'm gonna die on
whoa what's going on the one that one
dude says I spent the day in New Zealand
flew back to the US just to watch this
wow I'm impressed and I'm very happy
that you're here I hope you enjoyed your
time in New Zealand
Oh his open-world like the vision one so
yeah it's pretty much a similar setup it
seems seems very similar what package
you guys have on I assume it's probably
the gold edition yeah sure they usually
give you whatever has all the stuff in
it yeah for press press things why'd you
paint with a bunch of pre-order stuff
why would you play on PC with a
controller because third person games
play better with a controller I think I
feel I think and I feel I think
therefore I am
and there I am playing my PC third
person games with controller really oxes
they use a gamepad that's the that's the
words I live by that's the rules my boy
cosmic here you told me to live my life
one controller button press at a time
care I am getting triple West's rank
combos and Devil May Cry probably like
definitely cry with I'm willing to bet
there are there are people who play
trials with Nazis people which whoa real
talk if anyone hasn't put any thought of
that you're literally opting to play a
game that needs analog gas with digital
button inputs and that's nuts
that is pretty nuts I don't recommend
that but hey you know do what you got to
do
well that musics kicking editor out of
the complex and secure it
tactical asking the real questions do
the horse ball shrink in this game ooh
good good question haven't seen any
horses yet but once I do I will uh we'll
find out report back hey guys what's up
don't really run did you just not notice
I threw it I think we did but they just
kind of like latched onto a wall hoping
that it would work out part of the audio
bugs haven't had any audio bugs yet what
is happening with the screen right now I
think they were flashing oh yeah no
audio bugs
but can you fly boys wants to know
haven't had any flying yet either
that's an endgame thing can you solo
this game we've been solo waiting for
two hours now
yeah I soloed most of the first division
to 5050 I want to say yeah yeah I'm a
Janique probably solo you can solo it
but you probably don't wanna you
definitely want to play with friends I
don't have any
I wanted to awesome
that's a weird thing to say to somebody
yeah I'm gonna get you oh you got the
tutorial for manual reloading just I had
no idea I press X I reload
I have an i7 GTX 1070 how many FPS is
will you get probably a few you probably
fine honestly
yeah what the times 70 this weren't we
pretty sure this is like it I feel like
it's a 70 its I'm pretty sure it's a
10-7 I'm not sure the the salt you I'm
pretty sure that's it I didn't mean to
jump on top of that but I kind of look
cool yeah right I guess I'm supposed to
oh just wait never mind game looks dope
I'll be sharing time between this and
anthem like two stepkids dang wolf wolf
Scott it figured out that's not a
commitment yes better body armor there
sure this isn't on super easy or
something it didn't ask us for
difficulty so I'm assuming it's new and
never asked us for a difficulty it just
was like Harry guy who's the division
but it's not particularly hard
I've died like twice and that was from
like getting kind of ganged up or we
need just bein real cocky but I haven't
been a particularly challenging Oh
waffles is asking let us know is this is
Division one dlc or an actual decent
game it seems like there's content here
to warn enough being a regular game yeah
there's definitely not new new content
here for it to be a sequel as far as
whether yeah like changes enough for it
to be meaningful for you um I don't know
that's kind of to you I guess it's so
far he just plays a lot like the
divisional does that graffiti just say
drink yes yes it does Oh cuz you're on
the there's a bar here oh okay I'm
getting it I thought I thought it was
just randomly someone wrote drink
get them get them Randy go Randy the
roller mine of this shoot Randy got
another one actually I messed up I
wanted to throw Randy Wow
hold on hold on is there a story or a
number over there a lute game there's
story stuff first one had some story a
man find it particularly memorable but
it did have a story yeah
the story was basically like these
factions are trying to take over in New
York you should stop them
whoa-oh you've got people here at the
bar so we're playing early because we
have a special press access code unlocks
it normal times for everyone else but we
had to get in so when you get ready to
do our review and coverage so we got
special access to get in a few hours
with four hands so we're just in San
Francisco ultimate or special abilities
you get gadgets and later on down the
line you get to pick specializations
shumai boy
the guy's definitely dead got improved
improvised loves the theater real quick
and do some upgrades and then I think
we'll call it sounds like a plan gave me
the loot
have fun sorry I gotta get off the
street no one I guess well hey it's all
good thanks for hanging out I know where
he's been uh I hope you have a good day
I brought the head out anyway yeah I any
key
I had a key though maybe it's not a cool
enough key different key how does the
bullet impact feel there's a pretty good
sound when you headshot things yeah
feels okay I like the best I've ever had
but feels pretty good
when you get to start playing with
friends Institute Oriole you have to do
first I think as soon as you finish like
the beginning mission where you take
over the white house you'll probably be
able to yeah it seemed like we can
invite people almost right away
not that long maybe like just that
opening 20 minutes tutorial that's kind
of it yeah
thanks for showing us cool game guys hey
anytime happy to never just be here
hangout yeah I'm down to show off all
sorts of things don't hang out down to
down to clown
okay well head back to the fast travel
to the theater Ken heck yeah
is there matchmaking yes there is yeah
yeah there is matchmaking
anyways here's a little music to take
your mind off the stuff going whatever
he's doing climbing gloves
I should go throw my gear that's a lot
of work Marcus Janek Marcus giant rock
let's do it is this a video game yes
blue Hornet this is a video game do you
bet it this is a livestream of a video
game happening right now uh is that
supposed to be the dark zone on the
right side of the map so there it looked
like there were three different dark
zones that I could see just in wall John
Luke was going in and out of the menus
Oh check that out a sec agent oh heck
yeah a lot of people are getting there
in their tax returns these just to flip
that over onto the division oh yeah yeah
customization looks better than at them
yeah you get more parts oh definitely
it's a better loot game for sure in my
opinion how's the loot seems like
there's a pretty good variety haven't
gotten any new knee pads yet that's
disappointing that's the thing check out
these projects oh you finished one or
you're about to finish one throw it away
throw it away
nope guess that's it I think you
probably just choose what you put
everything into I think Oh for both
thing Isis then if I sell all my junk
here we go and yeah that's about it
that's the mission too you feeling it
yeah wrap it up okay only only two hours
in so yeah I I think it seems well made
I think if you like the first division
you'll probably pretty happy with this
yeah it seems like it's kind of more but
improved yeah but just the initial
impressions I'm just cool but I mean if
you aren't feeling the division I don't
think this is gonna change your mind at
all yeah yeah that's fair seems like
it's just kind of made to be a better
division but again we're only two hours
in so who knows say the game shapes up
yeah keep an eye out game sweats calm
for impressions or reviews or anything
we got coming up for it if you're
curious about it still and we'll get it
to you guys as soon as we can yeah yeah
all right thanks guys
goodbye everybody have a good day see
you tomorrow
hit the outro button there just found it
good bye